I grew up in Czechoslovakia
who then live there so my teens in
Prague in the city in the centre of the
heart of the city in the old city I was
an only child my father died before the
war so it was just my mother and me oh I
had two girl cousins that you know we
had oneness we lived in a city and we
had an apartment upstairs and these two
girls have and this was my mother's
brother and his wife and his two girls
lived downstairs and they were
practically my sisters you know we did
everything together
I more or less lived with them and they
didn't come back they were younger than
I was and I had kind of a high school
sweetheart a boyfriend whom I had had
for five years six years by the time I
went to campaign he was a highly gifted
individual musical and academically and
hit everything he didn't come back those
were the things that hurt is my you know
personal of course my mother never got
over the loss of her siblings she really
didn't I'm not aware of there being much
discrimination against Jews before the
war it was pretty open and integrated
society I remember some cat calling of
names on the street once but in my I was
in the public school and was large
Jewish minority there and there was an
influx of German immigrants and they
kind of thought Sofia wisdom which Antos
I'm 239 checks were saying oh it's not
going to happen here nothing is going to
happen here we are safe all right
and we still the kidding ourselves that
it's safe but then the Germans marched
in on March 15 39 that was kind of a
shock to the system I remember that day
very vividly I don't know why I went to
the post office and it was sleeting
and on a corner of the street they were
standing and a Czech policeman directing
traffic and the German soldier next time
who took over and the Czech policeman
stood there and he didn't know what to
do because the German had taken over
directing the traffic and it was kind of
a really plastic illustration of a
conflict of power the two of them
standing then the German taking over
he had had no warning at all my mother
started talking about immigration and
took me out of the public school and put
me into a private language school
because she wanted me to learn English
fast and so and afterwards that I was
kind of apprenticed in a trade because I
was supposed to have something I could
do when I came over to every we were
going and then first the public schools
were closed to deliver and allowed into
public schools and we went a lot into
restaurants then we went a lot into
parks and we weren't allowed into
schools then the this little workshop I
was working was you had to have special
restrooms for Jews and of course this
was like a workshop for it's ten people
and this was impossible for him the man
to comply with this kind of a man so he
had to let me go so by that time I was
realizing that things were different for
me October 42 we were caught up by a
notice to appear in the fairgrounds
there was a fair there are grounds there
in building a big building covered
building and to assemble for a transport
my mother and I went from Prague to
Tunisian start in Czechoslovakia and
that was still vision Czechoslovakia and
I guess we were lucky that we stayed
there for two years and I was working
and my mother was working and yet
acceleration so we did we let me lift
okay we also had a couple of passes from
home from some family that were not
Jewish in a room about the size of this
one that said 12 it could have been a
little bigger 12 by 8 18 it was longer
we went Celia BAM bunks and there was 35
people in that room it was a little old
house and there was the bathrooms where
the Hurva there was just to kind of out
houses on the in the hallway to serve
the whole house that was equally full
and one year the Red Cross Commission
came and they emptied out all the rooms
that were at street level you know and
put one couple in each room and moved
every 35 people relatively the
depending on the size of the room out
and just jammed us up more so that they
should could show the Red Cross how
humane this place was no I mean they
were flanked by Germans and you know
escorted su and shown around and the
streets they were taking su had been
cleaned up and the houses painted and
then the ground floor level there was
one couple in each room and they shot it
at cost is lovely settlement that was so
clean and nice they were never left by
the Germans so there was no way to get
to them I must say you know that while I
and my mother we were both young and
healthy at the time we're quite
comfortable a lot of people died and it
just from undernourishment and stress
and especially the older people I mean
the amount of food that seemed to be
sufficient for me or my mother also we
had some extras the old people died I
mean in the hundreds and thousands well
there was a call-up again it was two
thousand six hundred and fifty eight
people I know because I wasn't the last
carriage and this was number than
everybody was counted and we were in
cattle wagons they were covered at that
time I mean they work they had sleds but
there was a roof over them and this was
an October 44 and we went to Auschwitz
took two days 48 also better to get
there well we had two buckets from this
rotor and one for other needs and there
were two children in the car is last one
like a four-year-old and the six year
old and then there was an infant in the
car and those kids were so good it was
absolutely amazing
I I don't know it was I suppose I
managed to really kind of insulate
myself and say I wasn't really
participating and all that I built a
wall around me and said that's not
happening to me Ike it can't be true and
I'm not participating in this and I just
really shut myself off and that's how I
went through the whole war and then when
we arrived in Auschwitz in the evening
we could see this
rather than go see landscapers flesh
floodlights on the barbed wire which
went on for miles and miles and miles
and all you could see I just remember
when we've got out of the train in
Auschwitz that we were being separated
right on the platform as you stepped out
of the Train and sent left and right and
they wanted to separate me and my mother
and my mother said to me your mother and
daughter leave us together so he
motioned us to one side together
who held that whoever wasn't with us
there was 200 women where we were in the
morning was dead
they all had come straight to the gas
oven two thousand four hundred and fifty
six people we were taught rights a
minute we were separated and sent over
to that one side that this was all that
was left of the Train lot of people and
amongst this group was my girlfriend
whose mother had gone to the other side
and was my gym teacher whose children
had been sent to the other side that was
the first time I ever heard about gas
chambers I mean it was just too big and
too shocking to absorb my mother started
crying but I still somehow refused to
believe it I just didn't I suppose in a
way she knew that she had just never ly
escaped but I just was too monsters too
big was unbelievable there was a very
famous clarinetist with us too in the
Train and he had an eye infection he
wore dark glasses so he went to the gas
while they kept us in that one hole
which was cement floors and nothing else
all day and afterwards they asked us to
strip and we were shaved
I mean heads and body was shaved and we
were held it's who passed soldiers and
now I was like so you know 14 and I was
walking my naked past soldiers all the
time which really was after the first
day or so you get used to it but and
then we were herded into a bath house
was overhead showers by that time we
knew that the gas chambers were dressed
up as Charles and we decided there were
holes in the windows the glass was
broken this wasn't a gas chamber so
that's
and then we were herded into barracks
barracks long big wooden kind of Quonset
huts with service clangs people would be
relying six on one plank and when one
person wanted to turn we had six of us
to turn because there wasn't any room
for anything else the worst part for me
at the time was Weaver had to read a
roll call every morning this was in
Poland in October and Poland October is
cold and we didn't have much clothes
that issues us they didn't issue us in
uniforms uniforms are solid and
protective he had just been given all
the rags and he would stand on the Royal
Court from six o'clock in the morning
till eleven o'clock at noon or something
like that until every head in the canvas
accounted for and this was like hundred
thousands and the whole Corps would
never work and they come back and count
again and and in the evening again this
was way before dark till way into
daylight and in the evening again for
say four or five hours he would be
standing for work or and for the first
three or four days in ostridge we never
got anything to eat after first days
somebody complained to one of the carpus
and evidently he should have been issued
rations which hadn't happened so she got
us some soup that was the only food I've
got in six days in Auschwitz was one
soup we we we stayed together the group
of 200 of us who had been selected from
the from that transport and we were all
young healthy people I mean we had been
selected once over again when we were in
the bathhouse we had been selected naked
you know that's to it and again they
wanted to send my mother off and they'll
and then they asked her whether she had
somebody there and she said she had a
daughter they let her pass they were
about three women at her age in the
group the rest of us was all very young
I actually was in Auschwitz only one
week and then I was shipped off again
the last day we were standing outside
firms before dawn in the morning to dark
at night and I just didn't think I could
stand any more it was really my back was
playing up and we kind of huddled
together and supported each other
because we really couldn't stand and I
don't even give my piece of bread and a
piece of margarine and a piece of salami
for the trip and there was it was
given to us like that nothing to hold it
in or keep it in so the bread we kept
but the margarine and the meat I ate and
I got very sick screw-up immediately and
I also arrived in the camping in Germany
it was pretty high temperature I had any
action and they had kind we were well
the trip was quite something else again
this was now in or now this was to
cattle class this wasn't still the open
class I was beginning to doubt that I
would make it because I simply couldn't
stand anymore and I couldn't see how I
was going to get out of this and I guess
I by that time I really had the
temperature I was sick too I arrived in
Germany was a higher 42 degrees which I
don't know what Celsius which is quite a
bit he said was a small factory and we
had dry and heated sleeping quarters
that was big advantage they had had to
evacuate his labor on this work camp
where we were in this was April 45 and
they returned us to rest area instead
they had sent thousands and thousands of
people from all parts of Germany back to
today instead and as a matter of fact
that was the first time I saw these
photographs 'yes you know you see this
price of crops us the photographs of the
pile of corpses I think everybody has
seen by now and I think that much more
horrible thing is to see these corpses
walk and that was for the first time I
saw them walking into this typhoid and
cholera didn't place was liberation for
me and then they wanted us to stay there
and he rehearse you know and the chances
that we catch something they are really
pretty good so we got Red Cross parcels
in there we joined a laundry cart that
was taking laundry out of the camp and
smuggled our way out of the camp and
went back to Prague we went into a hotel
and he got two white beds with sheets
and linens and blankets there was hot
and warm and running water in the room
and I didn't know it could feel that way
and he both got sick we both are in bed
was a high temperature and there was no
public transport and nobody to call and
no food and
so then we remembered somebody from the
friends we had at the Embassy and miss
my temperature I picked myself up and
walked over there because my mother was
sicker than I and she gave us tea and
toast it was liberation the whole extent
of what had happened didn't it are still
after the war I mean like out out of my
mother's family out of there's a strange
there were certain people in my mother's
family know she was married
for now it's sisters and two brothers
with their daughters and sons and wives
and parents 13 went into camp nobody
came back and I had a group of young
people we used to meet in park just
before camps social group and out of all
my age and out of this group of thirteen
one came back I just pushed it away I
decide I couldn't think about it I
couldn't cope is it and I think it's no
more than five years now that I can't
even touch on it you know I really was
so busy I just think and repressing and
living and I just didn't want to I never
told anybody I when I met my husband who
was also from Czechoslovakia and spent
his four years in in Japanese camp we
did exchange information but I think
that's the only time I ever mentioned it
I never mentioned it to my children they
never and I never talked to them about
it then practically don't know that I
was in a camp what state was me the
defensive nastain not wanting to fear
not wanting to be involved but I'm very
aware now is of course the lack of
family and I bet I have been always
aware of I mean ever since I came to
this country I have this feeling of
being a waif of being alone in the world
which I am my husband lost his parents
he had one brother who has died since
because my husband died and I have no
family left